i wish teddy mellencam paul the best
said no one ever
lisa vanderpump is throwing some shade
at teddy mellencamp
the accountability coach was recently
fired from the real housewives of
beverly hills
my contract as a housewife is not being
renewed
and lvp jumped on her podcast to give
her two cents
i don't know people said because she was
boring i certainly didn't have a good
experience with her so
boring would be one of the nicer things
that i could say well
that not so boring experience is
probably about
do we dare say lucy lucy apple juice
dorite adopted lucy from our foundation
and then the puppy ended up
in a shelter as fans may remember lisa
left the show after hashtag puppygate
the story line that dominated season
nine i feel betrayed by you okay well i
feel betrayed by you
oh cause i couldn't carry out your plan
sorry teddy accused lvp of manipulating
her into bringing up claims about
dorit's dog on camera to make her look
bad why would elisa want
to make her close friend dorit look
bad because she was angry i think she
was angry about things that dried said
to her last year
and i don't think she was over it and i
think that she wanted to punish tree
and you know i think that i was an easy
person to help do that for her
but back to all things vanderpump lisa
also brought up the recent backlash
against teddy's weight loss program
which some claim that it encourages
disordered eating
there was something up contention about
her business something about 500
calories a day
i don't know how anybody can survive on
500 calories a day i think i eat
500 calories between 2 30 and 4 30 a.m
when i'm
up in the night but that controversy had
nothing to do with teddy's departure
something andy cohen cleared up on radio
andy
people are speculating that the online
chatter about her business led to her
dismissal
and i just want to say because i think
it's important that one had
absolutely nothing to do with the other
and i actually would have liked
to see her respond to her critics the
bravo icon
also raved about teddy's exit
announcement i don't want to
bore you but i figured i could give you
a little update on what's going on
of course i could give you the standard
response of
oh we both came to the decision that it
would be best
yeah i'm not going to do that that's not
who i am ready melon camp
released what i thought
was one of the most no bs
i'm leaving announcements on record
as for teddy's bestie kyle richards she
shared a touching instagram post writing
to my friend teddy mellencamp who i love
and adore
i am so grateful for real housewives of
beverly hills for bringing you
into my life i look forward to
witnessing what the universe has in
store for you next i know it's going to
be amazing you deserve it all
teddy kyle bravaholics may miss
these moments oh my god holy mother of
god going that night no we're not having
chips
but we're sure some of the cast won't
why can't you just say i'm closer to
teddy
what's wrong with that because you are
[Music]
excited
you